I have waited a very long time to meet
and speak with the most controversial
man on the internet no I'm not talking
about Donald Trump no I'm not even
talking about Andrew Tate I am talking
about
Prime Time 99
I'm talking about the man himself Alex
Stein
a comedian a provocateur absolute Terror
of members of Congress and school boards
all over this country I I'm sure you've
seen all of his videos I was just
recently watching one of him in a
leotard and a swimming cap complaining
about transphobia on the swim team as
Alex puts in his bio he has lots of
undiagnosed emotional and mental health
issues that are his secret weapon in the
fight against the New World Order
Mr Stein thank you for coming on the
show
wow
wow Michael what the heck that was such
a brilliant and eloquent introduction I
know I'm telling you this is my first
time appearing on a daily wire show and
I'm just so honored because in this
conservative space you guys are true
Champions what's your the work you guys
are doing at Delaware is very similar
hey you know you guys are obviously more
powerful than I am but we're fighting a
culture War you guys are doing a great
job so it's an honor and a privilege to
be on your show well thank you very much
and thank you for coming on so the
question I want to talk about a bunch of
videos and all this stuff I actually
want a longer period of time to talk but
we're stuck on Skype and it's 20 minutes
or whatever but the question I want to
ask
as I watch all of these videos and you
with absolutely no
fear no sense of propriety just going in
and a lot of them are just drop down I
mean the leotard one I was laughing out
loud
why are you the way that you are
well I like I said when my parents got
divorced Michael they fought for custody
of our family dog Primo more than me so
I was actually raised by a German
Shepherd more than I was by a two-parent
home so I come from the BLM Playbook of
the broken home and just like Saul
alinsky's Rules for Radicals the same
Playbook that Barack Obama and all these
freaks use on the left I'm using it on
the conservative movement I'm basically
using the rules for radical and using
the projection and just projecting all
of their crazy lunacy like the fact that
Leah Thomas swam on the men's team for
three years and then was able to take
some sort of medicine some you know
hormone therapy and was able to compete
against the women and become a national
champion in multiple events so it's
ludicrous it's absurd but that's where
we live in a world where the Supreme
Court Justice cantaji Brown Jackson
can't even Define what a woman is and I
know that is a Hot Topic in the daily
wire Community for the daily wire fans
you know that angle actually makes a lot
of sense to me because sometimes when I
watch your videos listen call me
old-fashioned sometimes I think ah you
know he's going a little far this is a
little much you know but but then the
way that you've just described it where
you say yeah I basically do what the
left does but I do it for the
conservatives I think well you know
there there's pretty much nothing that
I've seen you do that is any more
offensive than anything the left does
and it's probably much less offensive I
mean the left is killing babies and
trans and kids so obviously you know you
uh being sort of vulgar or something
like that is kind of in a completely
different category is that a
is that is that the idea behind this
performance art in many ways I guess I
would call it
well 100 my biological father Tucker
Carlson kind of coined it with me it's
called culture jamming where you take
the most absurd parts of our culture and
you jamming their face but it's funny
you say that though Michael because I
was recently the host of a concert with
a guy named Bryson gray Forgiato blow
and a guy named Tyson James they're
conservative rappers and Vice news came
and covered it and at the end of the
event it was a successful event there's
400 people it was fun we asked the vice
reporter because she actually kind of
had fun she was being nice and I have a
little heat advice uh for my
confrontation with Tesson but that's
neither here nor there back to my point
she said the only alarming thing to her
the whole entire event which was a
family-friendly event no cussing Bryson
is a secular rapper he doesn't even cuss
and I did jokes where I didn't cuss or
anything she said oh I didn't like that
there were so many children here because
there were a lot of kids a lot of
parents you know parents brought their
kids there
and then we asked her but what about
drag queen for story time and she's like
uh it's different so these people
literally want to sexualize children and
have them being read story times by men
in thongs that's okay that's social
justice but if you say abortion is bad
and that we want to save babies then
you're evil even people like Elizabeth
Warren that says crisis pregnancy
centers are demonic and satanic she says
they're the bad ones no one's trying to
save a life so that's how we're in the
upside down world I'm not even funny
Saturday Night Live isn't funny right
because they're too afraid of being
Politically Incorrect I'm Politically
Incorrect so I'm funny by default just
because I'm filling a void it's not even
that hard Michael right now head on over
to helixsleep.com Knowles I have had my
Helix mattress for about two years now
and I absolutely adore it it is
difficult to remember my life before my
Helix mattress now my Helix mattress is
for me your Helix mattress will be for
you why would you get in someone else's
bed you know what don't answer that
question when you want a bed for
yourself you got to go to Helix because
with Helix you take their very quick
sleep quiz about your body about how you
sleep and they will match a mattress up
for you they've got soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses for if you sleep a
little bit too hot they've even got a
plus size mattress for plus size
sleepers you take that quiz it's super
easy it's super quick Helix has over 12
000 five-star reviews they've got a 10
year warranty and you can try it for 100
nights risk-free they will even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but you
will love it and now for a limited time
cherry on top Helix is offering up to
350 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners this is their
best offer yet hurry on over to
helixsleep.com
Knowles so what what got you started
because I'm trying to think of the first
time I saw you it was relatively
recently So within the last year or so
and it was probably at one of these
school boards or something and I thought
man this is wild I haven't seen a
performance art like this in a very long
time and a man the guy is is a right
winger and you know and I just kept
seeing you pop up where did you come
from I mean am I did was I missing some
10-year career or something before this
that I just hadn't been aware of we
definitely need to do the hour-long
conversation but basically I started I
worked for a TV show Cheaters and I
signed in India I can only say so much
but the host of it was a very good
friend of mine named Clark Gable he died
of a fentanyl drug overdose he bought
pills that he thought were he bought
like Street Vicodin or whatever pain
pills and had Fentanyl and he died and
he was very close friends of them they
said Alex you're going to be the next
host of cheaters then when it came April
2020 and I'm like in the best shape of
my life this is my big opportunity
because I had worked in television I
also sold cars on the side literally
selling used cars that's why I love
creating content imagine getting on the
hot pavement 110 degrees for Hispanic
got to show you that there's a car
leaking the transmission's leaking it's
not that fun you know I'm just saying
doing this and playing make-believe you
know making fun of politicians is much
easier but my point being is at right
when I was supposed to get the job they
picked a 52 year old black guy named
Peter Gunz who God for you know God
bless him he's definitely good that he
took the job but my point being is the
show is syndicated by Viacom so they
changed his name from Peter Gunz to
Peter Panky and they just didn't want uh
another kind of 30 year old white guy
they wanted to go a different direction
which just makes sense but for me it was
a little bit of an affirmative action
and that kind of radicalized me to be
like hey I need to create my own podcast
I need to create my own thing so Michael
when I go to these meetings at the
beginning of the pandemic I went to the
mayor Dallas and was dead serious was
like you know why are we closing the
parks they turn off the water fountains
that my dogs drink out of at the park
you know and this is April in Texas it's
hot like how does this stop the spread
of anything and they looked at me like
and I was I was the biggest idiot in the
world just oh who is this conspiracy
theorist I mean just didn't show me any
attention and then when I noticed the
more absurd I got the more uncomfortable
they felt and I turned those NPCs those
non-playable characters and politicians
Intel oh now I can control them all I
want because now they have to get mad at
me they have to kick me out they have to
be embarrassed so yeah it's kind of just
it started off you know earnestly and
then I realized what's the most
effective is like I keep saying those
rules for articles is that we have to do
you know there's your times call call
cause for desperate measures whatever
the saying is we cannot use these uh
Orthodox tactics of being nice and
respectful we have to somehow use humor
to break people away or free from this
trauma-based mind control that the
mainstream media has everybody under so
how much of the ACT is you know a
sincere reflection of your political
views and how much of it is this sort of
olinskiite working around the system
because you know if we're locked into
this system the liberal establishment is
just going to continue to rule how much
of it is intentionally you know you you
say something you don't believe or you
you know you act in a way that you
wouldn't ordinarily act just to just to
get them to
jump out of their ordinary trains of
thought
yeah well I mean you could say like
shock factor for shock Factor but let me
tell you my political leanings is I'm a
populist I actually even though I'm now
a skew more conservative I am a tinfoil
hat proud Tempo hat wearing conspiracy
theorists I believe the weapons of mass
destruction that we never found in the
Middle East the 20-year war that we had
I just think that the government will
lie to us and they will pull all sorts
of tricks and I think the pandemic woke
a lot of people up to that so my point
being is when you have the populist
mindset and you know you want to say
well I'm conservative I want the
government left out of everything but at
the same time when I sold cars the
government made sure that I gave them an
inspection if I didn't give a customer
an inspection then you know I could be
liable to getting in trouble if I sold
them a lemon so it's kind of good that
the government gets involved in some
stuff but I don't want them because they
mess everything up but when it comes to
the Health Care System why is it that
insulin costs 200 in Texas but it's
seven dollars in Mexico but if I want to
get 10 000 vaccines that's all free so
we need a reallocation of funds now I'm
not saying we should have free health
care but we should make health care more
affordable I think that would just
benefit Society so even though I'm more
conservative if I really kind of
consider myself in the middle when it
comes to my political leanings I don't
like to say that I'm ultra far right
that's what they labeled me proud boy
far right when in reality that's that's
not the case I mean I'm anti-abortion
obviously there's some huge stuff that
I'm you know really staunch on that you
would say that's super conservative but
at the same time it's like I'm not
against Social Services I'm not against
helping people but letting a hundred
thousand uh you know drug overdose
happens because of fentanyl this past
year just having a wide open border
that's creating a welfare state I'm not
down with that so I like to consider
myself somewhere in the middle so
presumably you love Trump I mean Trump
kind of broke that mold and and at least
styled himself in 2016 as a populist
candidate
yeah well I like Trump too but then I
also don't like that he's you know with
the Johnson and Johnson family I don't
like that he didn't get Julian Assange
out of jail of course I love Donald
Trump I love when he's saying Little
Marco Rubio but he's not perfect now do
I want him to get his Redemption Arc yes
I want him to have round two and do I
think that that was the most fair in an
honest election ever of course and of
course Joe Biden got 81 million votes
duh you know it'd be impossible for him
not to but my point because I love Trump
I think he got a bad deal but there's
obviously some improvement that he needs
to do too uh and no Canada is perfect I
think Michael I say this all the time
idolizing a politician or celebrity is
like thinking the stripper actually
likes you they don't actually like us
They Don't Care About Us it's all just a
placate to us so yes I love Donald he's
the best one that we've had In Our
Lifetime but even Donald we have some
room for improvement right right you're
sort of damning with faint praise he
could be better than all the rest but
he's a politician a politician's a
politician so you used a phrase there
that really stuck out you said you want
his Redemption Arc and I I tell you the
the conservatives whose views I really
respect and especially those who have a
keen sense of kind of art and narrative
that's the phrase that they use they say
you know we hear from some people it's
not about Trump it's just about the
policies it's just about the country
it's just about this but the people who
I feel really have a good political gut
they say no it for better or worse it is
about this guy it actually is about this
guy and they booted him out and they
changed all the rules and they got and
they undermined his administration they
spied on him and they did all this stuff
and then they finally got him out and he
needs Redemption
so looking at 2024 you're a trump guy
yeah of course yeah I'm voting for Trump
and this is the thing I mean we know the
impeachment was garbage this January 6th
commission is the absolute travesty one
of the worst that I've ever been or
witnessed in my life I mean to think
that these people on January 6 obviously
you know if you really think the Q Anon
Shaman was going to go into Congress and
decertify an election you're mentally
ill all right and I'm talking to you
Nancy Pelosi because they actually
believe that they actually felt that
they were under some sort of threat now
you know is it good to go storm of
capital I don't know if that's
necessarily good but for them to treat
it like it was 911 the worst terror
attack in American history is it's just
very insensitive to the people that lost
loved ones on 911 so we live in a
government that will lie to us in order
to gain you know what they do is they're
going to trick us into trading our
freedom for safety but at the end of the
day we're not gonna have freedom We're
not gonna have safety and guys like
Donald Trump I believe wants to keep
some of our freedom left but it's a
slippery slope they kick him off the
internet you see Alex Jones they
bankrupt him for a billion dollars I
mean in this day and age you know if you
go against the counterculture even Elon
Musk who's been you know pretty liberal
he wants to put a computer chip in your
brain to be able to park a Tesla and
they still are going after him so with
these people if you have power and you
are a threat to the system you got to go
now so I'm very sympathetic to this
point of view and I agree that much of
the appearance of our political culture
is just kind of a sock puppet game and a
lot of it is just theater and regardless
of who wins or loses we always get more
immigration we always Outsource the jobs
we always get lose more and more of our
sovereignty so I'm with you on all of
that but then how do you avoid or do you
avoid getting totally black pilled and
saying oh well the libs have all the
power all hope is lost I might as well
sit on my couch and eat potato chips
yeah and the pseudos are really good if
you want to get estrogen and grow
breasts but my point being uh this is
this is what I'm saying is it's
impossible not to get black filled too
when you realize guys like Dan Crenshaw
that say their conservatives are giving
you know billions of dollars in the
Ukraine so for me I mean you know how do
we fight that that sense of like oh you
know Blackville like how do we
um you know get out of that mindset it's
difficult for me but at the same time
that's a harsh reality in which we live
in the government I don't think has our
best interest and it's just kind of
living positive and creating some sort
of future that you like because what
happens is they trick us into playing
their reindeer games you know they trick
you into wearing the mask they trick you
into getting vaccinated with the free
hamburger you know and if you don't fall
for their tricks then you can live a
happy life so getting black filled it's
impo it's impossible not to have that
feeling sometimes but there's a lot of
Hope and joy with being awake to
realizing breaking out of that cognitive
dissonance knowing that the government
you might think they have your best
interests but really they don't right
now go to meet fabric.com Michael being
a parent can be scary checking obviously
for monsters under your child's bed the
Indescribable pain of stepping on Legos
with your bare feet
one thing that does not have to be scary
is getting life insurance fabric by
Gerber life was designed by parents for
parents to help you get a high quality
surprisingly affordable term life
insurance policy in less than 10 minutes
Fabric's new lower prices mean
significant savings over other providers
with great quality policies such as a
million dollars in coverage for less
than a dollar a day life insurance can
have a bad rap for being complicated
fabric makes it super easy to apply with
its seamless digital experience
it's all online on your time if you need
extra support Fabrics team of licensed
insurance agents can answer questions
along the way
takes less than 10 minutes to apply see
your quote and personalize your quote to
fit your family's needs you could be
offered coverage instantly with no
Health exam required with over 1600
five-star reviews on trustpilot.com you
can feel confident that you are getting
a high quality policy for your family
they've got a 30 day money back
guarantee protect your family today with
fabric by Gerber Life at meatfabric.com
Michael that is meatfabric.com Michael
m-e-e-t fabric.com slash Michael
policies issued by Western Southern life
insurance company not available in
certain States prices subject to
underwriting and health questions so you
mentioned Crenshaw and you know I I saw
your video on Crenshaw and I thought
that was one of the examples where I
thought isn't this a little too far you
know yeah is Crenshaw more moderate than
I don't know then us and probably a lot
of the listeners yes but you know I like
the guy personally and I just is that is
that an example where you think you know
it's it's a little too impolite the
guy's a wounded veteran you know even if
I don't like his politics or do you
think no screw him I don't like him and
you know uh I'll say whatever
and I don't want to be insensitive to
Veterans I respect every single man and
woman in a military uniform but at the
end of the day the whole entire military
the military-industrial complex and the
imperialistic mindset that the you know
American Military has is disgusting I
mean I think about the millions of
people that died in the Middle East I
mean on World War II I think was the
last justifiable war that we've had so
when I look at people like Dan Crenshaw
and the other veterans that I talked to
that have been injured they become
staunchly anti-war I'm a conflict
interventionalist I will never say that
war is good and I know that's not
necessarily a conservative viewpoint but
I I don't think as human beings right
now we're fighting a proxy war against
Russia and Ukraine over the Don bass
region and for them not wanting to go
into NATO that's all we have to do is
just say they won't join NATO and keep
the dawn bass region autonomous where
they can choose whatever country they
want to go to and we're saying no
because we are benefiting from a proxy
war because people that it's not people
that run the country it is multinational
corporations like Halliburton like
Pfizer that can buy and sell these
politicians on both sides like toilet
paper through their political action
committee Dan Crenshaw is a guy that
kicked out service members from being in
the military through the National
Defense authorization act that weren't
vaccinated kicked out service members in
the Army Reserve that weren't vaccinated
so if he really cared about Americans he
would actually you know care about these
military guys that don't want to take a
vaccine that was tested on eight mice my
point being it doesn't matter because
these corporations are running and
calling the shots we're not being ran by
humans you think freaking Halliburton
could be empathetic when they drop a
drone strike on a wedding when we left
Afghanistan Joe Biden killed four
children nobody says a word about it so
you know it's just if these were human
beings running the country then they
would be more empathetic to other human
beings but at the end of the day because
these are CEOs we live in a
corporatocracy and not a real country
anymore sadly no you know I I don't
dispute a lot of that I I guess the
question I'm asking tactically is you
know if
in order to make that point are you
saying that the situation is just so
dire and the kind of the Public
Communication is so staged that it is
necessary to say and do things that are
impolite or rude or you know or immoral
even I mean because that's I just think
when I think about the Crenshaw thing I
think and you know given I I do like the
guy at a personal level but obviously we
have very different views on Ukraine he
and I and probably on a lot of other
issues too or I think about even AOC who
I don't like at a personal level and I
think you know it's one of your most
popular videos and it's one of those
things where you think this isn't this
is rude this isn't right I shouldn't but
you're kind of like giggling off in the
corner because it's kind of funny and
but you think you know
I don't know I couldn't bring myself to
say to say to a woman like hey you've
got a big booty and you're my favorite
well that's why I'm I'm insane Michael
and listen this is the other problem is
because if you look at the top movies
from the 90s it's like Shawshank
Redemption American Pie uh Pulp Fiction
if you look at the top movies of 2021 it
is literally uh other than Top Gun the
highest grossing movie was Sonic the
Hedgehog 2. so we need some political
incorrectness we need somebody saying
you got a big booty and I know that
that's no not the nicest thing and
probably not the you know uh you know
it's a little Unbecoming of a gentleman
at the same time it is harmless I am
complimenting her she is Jimmy from the
Block I mean I know she's not Jennifer
Lopez but she's from that you don't
think she's ever been cat called by a
construction worker I get cat called in
New York city so if she I do and I'm an
imbecile then I'm sure she's been
tackled so this is the point though is
when I go after guys like Crenshaw this
is his problem is that the NPCs are
talking about he gets so his ego is so
big and same with AOC is that they have
to react now when I made fun of Eric
swallow and I said oh did you and bang
bang you know did you guys you know and
you know what kind of sex did you have
with bang bang or you know did you sleep
with bang bang he was smart he's dead
silent kept his head down Adam kinsinger
same thing I made fun of him for dinner
but these these other politicians that
let me play with them in the video game
of life that's they're they shouldn't
get in the pig in the mud with a pig
like me Michael that's their problem so
it's just Dan Crenshaw if he didn't play
ball so much then I wouldn't have to
make him Persona nandra you know and
Public Enemy Number One so it's just
they if they were a little more down to
earth that that's the other problem
though Michael is that we have a Down to
Earth problem is these politicians as
soon as they get elected they have this
era of authority where they think
they're better than everybody and that's
not the case everybody has issues
everybody is the same and that's like a
socialistic kind of you know mindset but
really we all have problems we all have
issues and nobody is really necessarily
better than anybody else well that that
is the best explanation I've heard of
this is basically you're you're basic
you're going out there
to just see who will take the bait and I
think you're right about small well I
mean I think you're right the fact that
swalwell just
just kept on moving he said there's no
win here I'm obviously the moment I
react I'm gonna lose and he kept going
it's probably smart and some of the
other guys I mean I think you did one to
Jerry Nadler is that right
no that was a Pluckers I think Jared
nather that's a jury Nadler okay yeah
yeah but but I mean listen and I've
yelled and I've you know a beta O'Rourke
and you're getting their politician's
face and it's better for them not like I
just have to use that quote you know you
don't want to get in the mud with a pig
like me but this is other things we need
to humanize these politicians and we do
need to call them out now you saw these
guys that are actually liberal guys that
called out AOC for being a Warhawk and
that gets 10 million views because
people want to see these politicians
humanized and so that's what I try to do
is it's not even that I'm really trying
to be necessarily mean if you notice a
lot of my content I try to make myself
the butt of the joke because I don't
even really want to be me and I'm trying
to make fun of Myself by Asher turfing
as these crazy people or you know like
the whatever the status quo of the left
like saying you know my wife's boyfriend
dontarius
you know I bring up I have a lot of
little things uh that I can just use
that is basically uh become a symbol of
the left and that's the thing is we've
all become caricatures of ourselves
there's people in the far right that are
annoying there's people on the far left
that are known but for all these people
that talk about Q Anon it'll never talk
about the blue Anon for 2016 where they
said the election was stolen so it's
calling out hypocrisy is my point
Michael and that's what I want to do is
just try to call out the people
especially the mainstream media that's
hypocritical and the politicians I've
yet to meet very few Marjorie Taylor
green I've become friends with she's not
very hypocritical uh and you know Thomas
Massey that I've interacted with a few
of the ones that I've interacted with
that have been nice even Madison
cawthorne wasn't very hypocritical I
feel like I've dealt with a lot of
people that very few of them are
actually good the majority of them are
egomania who you know it's funny you
mentioned Marjory Taylor green because I
I hadn't met her before and I I
interviewed her not that long ago and I
had heard she's the crazy evil radical
Nazi whatever and then I'm chatting with
her and she's perfectly nice and polite
and saying saying things that are
perfectly normal and I kept waiting for
some crazy bomb throwing insane
conspiracy and that never happened she
was she was so different than how she's
been portrayed every everywhere on the
left and even in many quarters of the
right
no and I've become really good friends
of marjor and she even jokes you know
when they said the Jewish space lasers
that was taken out of context he was
talking about the anti-defense uh you
know anti-missile defenses I mean as
you're like I'm really trying to make
money
you know but she's literally just making
a joke and they make it like she's
anti-semitic and she's not she's a very
good friend of mine she's just I just
know that perfect and she's actually a
mom that cares about America that's what
we need we need more of those normal
people that actually go into politics
instead of these career politicians like
Joe Biden who's been in DC his entire
life and the country's only gotten worse
and so it's like we need more of these
people that are America first and then
aren't globalists and I know that's like
their tin foil hat what do you mean
globals is these corporations like I
talked about earlier Apple computer one
of the biggest corporations instead of
instead of you know building the phone
the Apple iPhone in America they
Outsource it to China and in China at
the Foxconn factories they treat their
employees so bad that they have suicide
Nets because so many employees are
jumping off the roof and in apple
instead of giving their workers better
wages they build bigger Nets so we need
politicians that aren't just going to
bow down to these corporations that
don't care about us and Marjorie is one
of them that has when you look at her
funding but when you look at the funding
of a guy like Dan Crenshaw it's all the
big you know the big dogs Halliburton so
if those guys are the ones paying these
politicians for me that's red flag we
need a human empathetic Viewpoint not a
corporation Robotech you know whatever
RoboCop whatever that company was from
RoboCop you know these or excuse me I'm
thinking of the the company from
um uh Terminator what is it but I can't
think of it but the dystopian futuristic
company that they see in all these
movies that's what they want to rule the
world I don't want that to happen no you
know I'm really glad you bring up the
the
corporationness of it all because for so
long for most of my political life the
Republicans just shelled and carried
water for corporations that absolutely
hate our guts that destroy our country
that gut our economy that open up our
borders that destroy our national
traditions and and we're over here
saying well you know you don't like it
build your own GE or whatever and it's
just so completely insane and I I just
love too for so many years on the right
you heard all these kind of Egghead
Think Tank takes on how well actually if
you want to have a good Society we need
to open up all the borders and give all
the money to the corporations and lose
all of our power because then at the end
of that somehow step B we're going to
leave that open but then step C you're
gonna have a great country and I thought
you know I don't know maybe I'm just not
sophisticated I don't have a PhD in Poli
SCI I just think maybe we should do good
stuff and avoid bad stuff is that is
that enough for a political philosophy
more good less bad that's what I want
well and speaking of the battle of good
versus evil now let me get real tinfoil
out for the daily wire I believe these
evil people are using it I think it's
out of the Bible it's uh it's the Tower
of Babel and then the Tower of Babel it
was a story about Nimrod wanted to build
the Tower to the kingdom of heaven to
kill God and in that when the tower got
pretty high God you know made them all
speak different languages and they broke
off in different tribes
what these corporations or these people
were trying to do is literally from the
Bible Genesis chapter 11 verse 9 I
flipped that that's 9 11. that's that's
just weird what I'm saying is they're
real they're reverse engineering the
Tower of Babel in order so there's one
ruler here on Earth and that would be
Satan that's the one world order that
they always talk about and that's
literally what they want I mean when you
look at the fact that it's such a big
deal that Ukraine's joining NATO why is
Russia why is that a big deal it's
because they don't want them to become a
superpower and that's already what we
basically have so it's that autonomy
America needs to go back to being
autonomous other countries need to go
back to being autonomous instead of
relying on each other and just being a
blank check to the Ukraine that is
what's going to help our country and
it's literally a satanic demonic game
plan and that's why these people that
say they want abortion up until birth
even when they ask people that are
pro-choice Michael hey you're a
pro-abortion but do you think there
should be a limit overwhelmingly people
say after the first semester or after
the second trimester trimester
overwhelming the pro-choice people
believe there should be a limit but all
these politicians want no limit they
wanted nine months or up until after
birth so it's demonic people that are
calling the shots and I don't know you
talked about it the point being is it is
a battle of good versus evil and knowing
that you're doing good I believe the
good will win in the end but it's not
going to be an easy uh road ahead that's
right the the middle part of that can
take a while I mean of course of course
it is one we know this is really basic
stuff from the Bible that Satan is the
prince of this world of this Fallen
World two you've got Joe Biden's Deputy
monkey pox coordinator taking pictures
of himself wearing pentagram leather
harnesses on his chest over his other
pentagram pectoral tattoo so this stuff
is there I mean you're seeing overt kind
of demonic imagery everywhere
but we'll unfortunately I have to leave
it there Alex there's so much more to
talk about we've got to get you out here
we're going to leave it on a cliffhanger
abuse then we gotta cut it we'll be back
no it'll be great I mean I we have to
get you back out that'll be the
Cliffhanger folks the the overt demon
worship that we're seeing from the
Satanic Biden Administration that's the
Cliffhanger whenever we can get Alex
Stein out to Nashville we will uh take
it up from there and hopefully go a lot
longer Mr Prime Time 99 Alex Stein thank
you for coming on people can find you
over at the blaze correct yeah I'm at
the blaze I got a new show coming out at
the first of the year uh The Primetime
Alex sign show and you know the daily
wire I gotta applaud you guys you guys
were just dominating so uh yeah I like
it birds of a feather flock together so
Michael it's an honor and a privilege to
come on your program today thanks man I
appreciate it and I look forward to
seeing you for much longer sit down
[Music]
[Music]